the Star Trek the Next Generation crew
went for one last ride in the third
season of Picard but suppose credits
tease seems to indicate the story will
continue with the generation after that
now that Star Trek Picard is over the
series has bid fare well after 36 years
of Patrick Stewart as the iconic Captain
Jean-Luc Picard it has also set the
stage for his legacy to continue through
jack Crusher played by a delightfully
energetic and speliers Jack is a son
Picard never knew he had born of the
former staff League Captain's romantic
involvement was Dr Beverly Crusher
furthermore Jack has revealed over the
course of Picard's season 3 to be
carrying the burden of some strange and
dark abilities in the finale's
post-credits scene Jack is settling into
his quarters aboard the USS Enterprise
when a visitor arrives this turns out to
be none other than the immortal powerful
trickster known as Q the card fans will
remember that Q was behind the events of
season two and was presumed dead after
using the last of his powers to send
Picard and his crew back to their own
time here he urges Jack not think in
such a linear way telling the young
Ensign young mortal
much ahead of you jack points out that Q
promised Picard that Humanity's trials
were over to which the demigod replies
that his dad's trials are indeed over
but Jacks are just beginning it seems
clear that this post-credits scene is
setting the stage for a TV show or movie
focused on Jack and who better to give
him his first challenge than his
father's old Frenemy it's Belize has
already hinted at a jack Crusher
spin-off but this Star Trek Picard
post-credits scene appears to confirm
that such a project is in the works in
an interview with Cinema Blend in
February spaliers revealed that he's
spoken to showrunner Terry matalis about
Jack's future saying he's got a lot of
ideas about it I'm not gonna lie because
I'm proud of the fact that Terry and I
discussed this almost every day for the
last 18 months what could happen the
actor also noted there were definitely
more stories to be told if we're given
the opportunity to tell them and I know
that Terry has bucket loads of ideas
facing off against Q would be a fitting
right of passage for Jack since the
first episode of Star Trek the Next
Generation encounter a Far Point
introduced his Captain Picard to viewers
by putting him against Q as well in that
episode Q acts as judge and jury for the
human race reminding Picard of
Humanity's crimes and History of
Violence the final episode of The Next
Generation all Good Things bookends a
series with q's involvement once again
will Jack face similar judgment all his
trial by Q be of a different nature
entirely that's the mystery posed by the
Picard finale's post-credits scene and
one to which fans likely won't have an
answer until we see Jack again writing
the opening line to your legacy matalis
first revealed that he has a concept for
a Star Trek Picard's spin-off titled
Star Trek Legacy in a March 23 2023
tweet however he'd sold Screen Rant a
few weeks later days prior to the Picard
finale's Premiere and Paramount had yet
to Greenlight this project he said he
was merely sharing that he has ideas
should the company express interest of
course SuperCard finale's post-credits
scene seems to confirm that the series
is a go after all what Paramount allows
such a blatant Cliffhanger without at
least some sort of plan in place to pay
it off in a brief Entertainment Weekly
interview about Al Picard ends matalis
said Jax got a lot to do let me tell you
this cryptic comment seemed to reinforce
the idea that Jack crushes conflict with
Q will soon become the focus of a brand
new Star Trek project for now fans will
simply have to wait for more news about
the continuation of Jack's story